Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today, I’m
going to explain a science fiction
action film called “The Discovery.”
Spoilers ahead! Watch out and take care!
At the beginning of the movie, we see
professor Thomas Harbor being interviewed.
He has recently proven the existence of life after
death. The interviewer claims that his discovery
was dangerous, because ever since his work was
published, the suicide rate has been skyrocketing.
He dismisses the claim by saying that such a
crucial truth about human life had to be brought
to people, regardless the consequences. Thomas
has been able to capture brain wavelengths on a
subatomic level leaving a person’s body when they
die. This explains that a person’s consciousness
goes somewhere when they die. But the interviewer
insists that since they do not know where
consciousness goes, they cannot tell for sure if
the afterlife exists. Thomas tackles the claim,
saying that when a train leaves the station, we
know it is going somewhere. She then brings up
that many celebrities, athletes, and hundreds of
civilians have ended their lives because of the
professor and asks him if he feels responsible
for their deaths. Thomas simply answers that he
doesn’t. Just then, one of the camera crew stands
before Thomas and thanks him for a “fresh start”.
He shoots himself dead right after. In a similar
fashion, people have been committing mass suicide
to restart a new life in the afterlife.
It is now the second anniversary of the discovery,
Thomas’s son, Will Harbor is traveling on
a ferry, listening to a TV program talking
about his father’s discovery. As it turns out,
the suicide rate has not decreased ever since.
Will turns the TV off, making it clear that he is
not proud of his father’s work. A girl from the
other seat startles him. They are the only ones on
the ferry. She introduces herself as Isla and Will
comments that her face looks very familiar. The
two chitchat for a while. The conversation turns
to them talking about the discovery. Isla is a
supporter of it, but Will exclaims that he doesn’t
believe in it. Isla claims that the discovery gives
people a way to get relief from the sufferings of
life, but Will stays adamant about his view. After
they get off the ferry, Isla hitchhikes in a car,
leaving Will at the harbor. His brother Toby comes
to pick him up. The two drive to a huge mansion
bought by their father. Thomas has built his new
station in the mansion, and has employed people
who survived attempted suicides. Will is confused
to see labs and machinery inside the house. Thomas
has been conducting some kind of experiment.
Will meets his father and bluntly asks him to stop
all this. He wants Thomas to tell the media that
his discovery was false and stop the chain of mass
suicides. Thomas laughs at his idea and claims
that his discovery was a hundred percent true
and he won’t lie to anyone. As it turns out,
Will was the inspiration for the discovery.
When Will was young he had an accident and
died for a minute. When he was resuscitated,
he had told his parents that he saw flashes and a
little boy in front of him. This provided Thomas
with the idea that life after death might
exist. Hence, Will blames himself for the
deaths and wants his father to stop. After the
conversation, Will goes outside to cool his mind,
but just then, he sees Isla on the beach nearby.
She seems to be packing her bags with weights.
Isla wears the heavy bag and goes into the sea.
Will realizes she is about to commit suicide,
and runs to save her. He goes into the water
and manages to save her, but Isla is furious.
He takes her to the mansion and asks Toby to take
her in, since they help people who are suicidal.
Toby agrees but she will have to go through
the questionnaire first. Isla is surprised
to discover Thomas is Will’s father.
Thomas then conducts an interview with Isla,
asking her questions about her life. Meanwhile,
Will goes around the house and sees that it has
been fully converted into an establishment
with canteens and rooms for every patient.
At night, everyone gathers in a room while
Thomas presents something to them. He brings
out a man with a device attached to his head
and claims that he has figured out a way to see
the afterlife. Till now, the world only knew that
our brain waves leave for somewhere after we die,
but now he has figured out a way to see where
the brain wavelengths go. Will and the others
are shocked. Thomas explains that with the device,
they can see a video recording of the afterlife.
Later, everyone is at Thomas’s office. He wants
to be the first one to be experimented upon,
but he has to be dead for that. Hence, they
decide to perform it on an already dead person
which they have to steal from the morgue. On their
way there, Toby reveals to Isla that their mother
committed suicide and Will blames his father for
it. At the morgue, Toby distracts the keeper,
letting Will and Isla to successfully steal
a corpse of a man named Philips.
That night, Will and Isla sleep on a bunk bed
together. Will tells her that his mother killed
herself on the day of his parents’ wedding
anniversary. His father was never attentive
and she was left hopeless when Thomas didn’t come
out of his office on their anniversary. Will had
found her dead body in the bathtub the following
morning. The two talk for a while and sleep, while
holding hands. The next day, everyone is ready to
perform the experiment. They attach the corpse’s
head to the device and hit a button. While Thomas
waits for something to show on the monitor,
nothing happens. They do it repeatedly, but to
no avail. A disappointed Thomas leaves the room
and everyone else follows. However, when Will is
alone inside, the monitor starts working and shows
a clip of Philips meeting a woman at a hospital.
Will quickly turns it off before Thomas comes
in again. They have to let Philips’s body go for
cremation and Thomas asks Toby for a new corpse.
Will and Isla take the corpse back to the
morgue and leave it on the ground outside.
All of a sudden, Isla kisses Will, the two are
awkward later and do not talk on the ride home.
Will cannot get the thought of the video out of
his head. He has downloaded it to his laptop.
After some research on the internet,
he finds the hospital in the video.
Will dives to the hospital and walks
through the passage Philips had walked.
However, he reaches a dead end that was not in
the video. A janitor informs him that there used
to be a passage before the hospital was renovated
a decade ago. Will realizes that the video could
not have been from the future, he predicts
it to be Philips’s memories displaying on
the monitor. His father had made a memory device
rather than something that shows the afterlife.
Later, everyone gathers at the mansion for a
session, when Thomas calls a patient named Lacey
to the stage. Lacy has been speaking against
the discovery and Thomas’s new invention,
claiming that it will cause more mass suicides.
Thomas confronts her in front of everyone.
As it turns out, he had found Lacy
in the woods ready to kill herself,
and had saved her. In the end, he asks her
to pack her bag and leave the establishment.
Will is furious at Thomas for embarrassing
Lacey, but Thomas dismisses the matter.
Later, Will shows Isla Philps’s video. The two go
to the same hospital to investigate Philips's case
together. They find Philips’s father’s file with
his address on it. They believe that in the video,
Philips was visiting his father on his deathbed
and the woman he met was probably a relative.
Later that night, Will has a chat with Toby who
tells him that Thomas has been working on this
machine for their mother. Thomas is guilt-ridden
because of his wife’s death and wants to know she
went to a better place. The following day, Will
and Isla go to the beach, where Isla tells him
that her five-year-old son had died by drowning
in a beach because she fell asleep. That was
the reason she wanted to die before Will saved
her. The two then go to Philips’s house and meet
his sister who happens to be the woman from the
video. She informs them that Philips never came
to meet her father at the hospital. None of his
family likes him, as he had been awful to them.
Will has noticed a tattoo of a lighthouse on
Philips’s arm in the video but the woman tells him
that he had a wave tattoo instead. Will realizes
the video is not Philips’s memory but rather,
his afterlife. Philips has gone back
in time to correct his mistakes in life
after his death. As it turns out, in the
afterlife, people relive an alternate
version of their life and get a second
chance to make different choices.
Will and Isla are surprised by the discovery. They
are in their room when suddenly, Toby barges in
and calls them to see Thomas. Thomas has attached
himself to the device to try to figure out the
machine. He has suffocated himself and is on the
verge of death. The monitor starts working again.
This time, it shows Thomas on the night of his
wife’s death. It was their anniversary. He had
not come out of his office that day, but in the
video, he tells his wife that work can wait and
has dinner with her. He had been given a
chance to correct his mistake, and he did.
Right after watching the video, they unplug
the machine and bring Thomas back to life by
electrocuting him with a defibrillator. Thomas is
shocked and delighted to see his device work.
It turns out that when a person dies, he goes back
to a time in his life that he regrets the most,
and gets a second chance to
make different choices.
He gathers everyone in the house in the front
yard and is about to tell them about the invention
when suddenly, a gunshot is heard. Lacey,
who has been kicked out of the mansion,
has shot Isla. She claims that she didn’t kill
her, just gave her a new beginning before being
taken away by Toby. Isla falls to the ground and
tells Will that she doesn’t want to die anymore.
Will is devastated when she takes
her last breath in his arms.
Sometime later, we see Toby and Thomas talk
about Isla’s family for a police report.
Thomas decides to destroy the machine after
seeing the impact it has on people.
But when Thomas tries going inside his lab, he
discovers that it is locked from the inside.
Will locks himself, and attaches himself
to the device. He suffocates himself
and when he is on the verge of death, Will
finds himself in a memory of himself back on
the ferry. Will meets Isla again and asks her what
is going on. Isla reveals that this is a memory,
because Will is connected to the machine and is
not yet dead. Isla here is his own subconscious.
In the memory, Isla reveals that he has been
living this part in loops in multiple lives.The
two first met on the same ferry many lives ago.
But in that scenario, Will didn’t see Isla trying
to commit suicide, and couldn’t save her. When
he read about her death the following day,
he was filled with guilt because he knows he
could’ve done something on the ferry. He went on
living his life but the guilt always remained with
him. Eventually, when he died, he was brought back
to the ferry where he met Isla again, because
he regretted this moment the most in his life.
However, Will couldn’t save her even then.
In the similar way, Will has been stuck in this
loop and lived his life hundreds of times trying
to save Isla. But he'd never been successful until
his most recent life. Will has met her numerous times,
so a part of his consciousness remembers her.
That is why Isla looked familiar
to him when they first met.
Isla tells him that since he has been able to
stop Isla from committing suicide in this life,
he has made peace with his consciousness and
has no regrets now. Also because of that,
he would now end up somewhere else in his next
life, and not on the ferry. Will promises that
in his next life, he will remember Isla.
Just then, he begins to hear the voices of Thomas
and Toby. They are trying to jump-start his heart,
but their attempt is unsuccessful and Will dies.
After he dies, his afterlife takes him back to
a beach. Will sees a little boy is alone playing
in the water. He takes him out, making sure the
kid doesn’t drown. Just then, Isla comes running
to them, and we see that the kid is Isla’s son.
Will now has been sent to save him. Isla thanks
him and walks away with her son. Neither of them
recognize the other. As Will walks away,
he turns around with a confused look on his face,
suggesting that he is starting to remember Isla.
The movie ends, but we can imagine
that Will perhaps asks Isla out for
coffee or something afterwards.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on notifications, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thank you for watching.